Lauren bobbert is a disgrace to this
country I'm going to talk about Howard
Stern for a second because he had a clip
now it's interesting because Howard
Stern was the he was the king of radio
he used to call himself the king of
media Howard Stern again I grew up in
New York City I used to listen to him
when he was on what was it 92.3 if I'm
not mistaken or 90s what was it what was
his it was W well eventually he was on
wnbc but whatever it was when he was on
AM radio in in New York City and and
became absolutely huge eventually went
to SiriusXM it's a little bizarre cuz I
it's hard to tell if he has any cultural
relevance anymore other than he says
stupid things every now and again and
then people respond to it anyway he went
after Lauren bobbert because you know
the other day Lauren bobert got her boob
squeezed and people were freaking out
and you know again some people like
squeezing boobs some chicks like getting
a boob squeezed we can debate all about
that till the cows come home um but but
uh Howard Stern went off on Lauren bber
you'll see how I'm connecting this to
everything else go Lauren bobbert is a
disgrace to this country not because the
VD you are 100% right forget the
politics she's in a a titty dress if you
saw the video she's in a titty dress
she's with some dude looks like she's
you know obviously vaping but also looks
like she might be grabbing his penis
during uh Beetlejuice and uh her and
he's playing beet juice a sexy play it's
a very erotic play evidently I I
remember the movie it was nothing sexy
about it you didn't grab anybody during
the I guess the play is much hotter uh
but uh but she was wearing a tight titty
dress I I've seen porn stars wear
more okay so I want to explain how I'm
linking this all together and just
quickly on Howard it's turn you know my
first gig really my first sort of paying
like legit media gig was at SiriusXM I
had a weekly Sunday show at SiriusXM
Howard had his own Wing over there at
Sirius and then the rest virtually
everybody else you know there's a
hundred other Serius channels sports
channels Lifestyle Channel channels
celebrity channels everything else we
were all on another side as him but I
always wanted to say hi to him and see
him I've had many dreams in my life that
I would be on Howard Stern when I wrote
my two books the only show that I asked
my agents to get me on I didn't care
about any other show was Howard Stern
Never Never Happened does doesn't matter
I've lost a lot of respect for him over
the years his coid stuff has been insane
his politics are all completely just
standard leftist backwards whatever
Howard CERN did once interview Harvey
Weinstein before the whole thing blew up
and uh take a listen to this why not
stay I got to figure every Starlet in
Hollywood want to at least blow you you
know what I'm saying did you did you
ever get to experience the I'm going to
say the Mogul aspect I mean do a little
Coke you know hang out with uh you know
I don't know uh Julia Roberts give you
hand job something you never got any of
that Howard as you know only too well it
doesn't work that way it doesn't really
I'll tell you who it works that way for
it works way for the
actors every girl knows that that that
if she's a competent actress if she
could get on your good side you could
make her a star over night don't
tell me it doesn't work I wish it I wish
the the movies are too expensive the
risks are too great it doesn't happen
that you can't walk into the room pull
your pants off and say okay honey let's
talk all right so first off obviously
Weinstein is lying there and and again
I'm only bringing this up because look I
I don't care about people doing drugs
privately I don't care about people
getting hand jobs everyone I know has
gotten a hand job from Julia Roberts I
mean come
on Brock was like yeah right well one
time yes I um the point is that he's on
one hand these are the cultural taste
makers and when you're a leftist you can
do and say anything and you're protected
and when you're not they'll destroy you
so bobbert got her boob squeeze we got
to take her out Howard cern's been doing
this
for